[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi à 28 mars
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tour d'horizon de l'actualité locale est
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
la france et les yvelines se souviennent
à d'arnaud beltrame en ce jour d'hommage
national aux lieutenants colonels morts
lors des attentats de vendredi
plusieurs cérémonies se déroulaient dans
le département minute de silence à
versailles ou encore à montigny le
bretonneux
c'est le troisième centre du jour en
ile-de-france une station d'hydrogène a
ouvert ses portes dans la commune des
loges en josas une promesse celle de
produire un carburant nouvelle
génération 100% écologique
le lieu était inauguré ce mercredi matin
en présence des élus locaux
et puis invités de ce journal jean
frédéric poisson président du parti
chrétien démocrate ancien candidat à la
dernière primaire de la droite et du
centre à l'ex député des yvelines a
lancé un appel à droite s'ils demandent
un dialogue en vue des élections
européennes de 2019
on parlera également dans ce journal du
plan local de l'habitat de saint quentin
en yvelines qui doit être votée cette
année en plateau avec nous à tout à
l'heure
even longchamp vice-président du codis
qui est richard tellier directeur du
claj saint quentin en yvelines à
l'hommage national ce mercredi à arnaud
beltrame cérémonie aux invalides à paris
mais aussi dans les yvelines
la ville de montigny le bretonneux a
observé aujourd'hui à 14h30 une minute
de silence dans la salle du conseil
municipal
plus d'une cinquantaine de personnes
présentes pour se souvenir du lieutenant
colonel de gendarmerie tomber en héros
il avait pris la place d'une otage dans
le super u de trèbes lors des attaques
terroristes de l'aude vendredi dernier
le gendarme avait succombé ensuite à ses
blessures dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi un sacrifice dont il faut se
rappeler pour le maire de montigny le
bretonneux interrogé par as nicolas
kirillovitch je pense que la démarche
que ce colonel a fait en sacrifiant sa
vie pour sauver celle de quelqu'un
d'autre est tout à fait exceptionnel
dans l'histoire de france et un moment
donné
nous en tant qu'élu mais également tous
les représentants de la population de
montigny nous avons souhaité faire cet
hommage
non seulement c'est important mais c'est
même indispensable cette cette barbarie
de l'islamisme c'est en étant tous unis
tous vraiment solidaires qu'on arrivera
je ne dis pas à l'éradiquer mais au
moins à la combattre il faut vraiment
que nous soyons fermes sur les valeurs
qui sont celles de la france et que nous
nous battions tous et c'est l'action de
nous tous au quotidien qui permettra je
dirais de passer des messages et de
multiples hommage au lieutenant colonel
de gendarmerie ont eu lieu dans les
yvelines ce graphe d'abord de l'artiste
cette nuit-là vrai été réalisé dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi dans le centre
ville de port marly ce message
soyons fiers de son courage et
n'oublions jamais son sacrifice
une minute de silence a été aussi a
suivi en simultané ce mercredi matin au
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
et à la préfecture à versailles
après des études au lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école arnaud beltrame avait
été affecté au peloton de véhicules
blindés à satory entre 2002 et 2006 en
2015 il était revenu à versailles pour
intégrer l'école européenne
d'intelligence économique est la ville a
d'ailleurs décidé de donner à une rue le
nom est d'arnaud beltrame
je vous en parlais dans les titres
invités de ce journal jean frédéric
poisson dans soir bonsoir
vous êtes le président du parti chrétien
démocrate on parle avec vous de cet
appel que vous allez vous avez lancé à
droite pour un dialogue en vue des
élections européennes de 2019
cette question déjà l'hommage national
ce matin au lieutenant-colonel arnaud
beltrame qui a notamment servi dans les
yvelines quel regard vous portez sur le
sacrifice de cet homme c'est un acte
humain exceptionnel
c'est l'acte d'un homme qui était animé
de valeurs spirituelles chrétienne qui a
manifesté une immense cohérence une
certaine façon entre ceux qui y croire
et ce qu'il fait c'est un sacrifice qui
n'a pas beaucoup de d'antécédents pas
beaucoup de précédent dans l'histoire de
notre pays en tout cas récente et il
mérite très très amplement ce message
qui fasse cet hommage qui lui est rendu
en france par le président de la
république ce matin dont j'ai apprécié
discours et dans notre département où le
colonel beltrame a servi j'associe à cet
hommage la marche blanche qui se déroule
en ce moment à paris en hommage à madame
noël qui a été assassiné dans le cadre
d'un assassinat antisémite d'une
barbarie incomparable et que ces deux
personnes soit unis dans un même hommage
national aujourd'hui est un signal pour
notre pays qui est je crois fort et qui
nous invite comme le disait le maire de
montigny-le-bretonneux à l'instant dans
votre reportage effectivement mieux
vivre et vivre davantage et plus
énergiquement encore les l'ensemble des
principes et des valeurs qui constituent
notre société alors l'année passée a été
riche en scrutins prochaines échéances
électorales cc européenne dans un peu
plus d'un an mais 2019 certains partis
sont déjà dans la course la république
en marche a lancé sa grande marche pour
l'europe
à droite les transactions ont également
débuté vous justement jean frédéric
poisson vous avez appelé la semaine
dernière un dialogue à droite en vue de
ce scrutin un dialogue pour diluer je
vous cite le projet de dilution de la
france compte réparé dans ce projet donc
de dilution de la france d' emmanuel
macron que vous reprochez vous juste à
la politique du président la république
à elle est fondée cette politique sur
des principes auxquels je suis opposé un
par un il les a décliné ces principes
dans son discours d'athènes et son
discours de la sorbonne c'était l'an
dernier autour de l'été c'est d'abord la
souveraineté européenne de préférence à
la souveraineté nationale
c'est ensuite une société
communautariste il est le seul candidat
aux présidentielles à s'être prononcé en
faveur du fameux taffetas vous savez le
traité d' échanges transatlantiques avec
les états unis
et puis il met en oeuvre un renforcement
très très important des pouvoirs de
l'état souvent au détriment des
collectivités territoriales des familles
des entreprises c'est également un
élément de sa politique assez peu vu
mais qui est une réalité et donc sur
chacun de ces points je suis en
désaccord profond et c'est malheureux
d'une certaine façon parce que ce sont
les principes de son de son projet alors
vous allez le long si nous voulons
pardon en une phrase résister à ce
projet il faut consulter nos positions
qu'ils soient point par point
al'inverse des principes qui sont
portées par le président de la
république à commencer par cette
question de la préservation de
l'indépendance le peuple français c'est
la raison pour laquelle il me paraît
normal que tous
qui s'y opposent cette vision se
rassemblent et donc diallo mais vous
parlez des manuels macro injustement
comme quelqu'un de rohff il justement à
droite il y en a des europhiles
notamment dans le parti des républicains
ah mais c'est cher monsieur je suis moi
gros fils j'ai pas de problème avec
l'europe
je suis européen comme vous et je suis
comme n'importe quel français
est ce que vous redoutez aujourd'hui
c'est que la france
disparaissent dans l'union européenne
voilà vous soucier parfaitement résumé
je fais la différence entre l'europe et
l'union européenne
oui à l'europe non à l'union européenne
non plutôt non à l'union européenne
technocratique de bruxelles qui dicte un
certain nombre de principes de volonté à
des peuples qui n'ont même pas la
possibilité de s'y opposer en réalité
donc ce qu'il faut c'est n'ont pas
abandonné l'europe l'a quittée en partir
je sais pas comment on pourrait découper
la france de l'europe pour qu'elle parte
au large
je sais pas où ça n'a pas de sens en
revanche imaginer une construction
européenne dans laquelle les nations est
tout leur poids et la possibilité de
prendre en main leur destin ce qui
aujourd'hui sur un certain nombre de
sujets n'est pas possible mais je suis
le premier à reconnaître d'ailleurs je
l'avais dit pendant la campagne primaire
et présidentielle en 2017 2016 2017
il y à des sujets que nous devons
traiter avec nos voisins européens parce
que c'est impossible autrement
mais ça ne veut pas dire se faire
imposer par des instances européennes
qui viennent de nulle part des choses
que nous ne voulons pas alors vous
disiez tout à l'heure que ce dialogue
pourrait aller plus loin proposé par
exemple une candidature une seule et
candidature unique pour ces européennes
est ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui
quand on voit les réticences par exemple
des républicains de recevoir un soutien
du front national lors des législatives
partielles à mayotte une seule
candidature à droite est ce que c'est
possible
aujourd'hui j'espère que c'est possible
parce que ça voudrait dire que nous
sommes capables collectivement d'offrir
inde afin de proposer une offre
politique homogène à la fois sur le plan
des idées et sur le plan électoral à
tous les français qui ne veulent pas de
cette europe là donc le dialogue il me
serait que le aujourd'hui que le front
national d'être avec debout la france je
dresse vous avez fondé
m la fronde et les amoureux de la france
à l'automne dernier donc ce dialogue
existe déjà avec eux debout la france
avec le soutien des indépendants avec le
mouvement pour la france avec d'autres
mouvements qui ici sont qui se sont
joints également à cette initiative
j'appelle de mes voeux qu'effectivement
tout ceux qui sont d'accord sur ce
projet se rassemblent pour constituer
encore une fois cette opposition là je
ne raisonne pas en termes d'étiquette
politique dite partis politiques et
d'organisations d'accord je veux d'abord
qu'on élabore un projet sur la base
duquel ceux qui veulent venir dialoguer
travailler avec nous sont les bienvenus
dernière question même s'il ya une
alliance à droite s'opposer à l'action
du gouvernement via ce scrutin ne
serait-il finalement pas un coup d'épée
dans l'eau quand on voit le peu de
passion qu'il ya dans ces élections des
français 43 % de participation lors des
dernières européennes inquiète atteint
40 % aux européennes précédentes donc ça
progresse il faut un petit peu
d'optimisme et dans le je crois dans le
bon sens des français je pense que cette
élection est une élection qui les
intéressent peu à partir du moment où
ils ne comprennent pas que ça puisse
changer quoi que ce soit à leur vie si
on leur propose quelque chose
une orientation un projet politique qui
leur dit c'est à vous que doivent
revenir les décisions parce que vous
récupérerez de la souveraineté et du
pouvoir sur la commission de bruxelles
qui est une espèce d'organismes aveugle
dont personne de comprendre l'action à
ce moment là je pense que d'abord c'est
susceptible de les intéresser davantage
et deuxièmement on a besoin de cette
dynamique nouvelle dans l'opposition
pour faire en sorte que effectivement ce
qui est en train d'être fait par le
président de la république soit contrée
salle l'état cpe aujourd'hui mais vous
voyez bien que je vis bien au delà des
européennes qui n'est qu'un moment dans
la marche générale de ce que je crois
nécessaire pour redresser notre pays
un merci à jean frédéric poisson est
avec toi je rappelle président du parti
chrétien démocrate est dans l'actualité
du jour c'est une première dans les
yvelines une station et d'hydrogène a
été inauguré ce mercredi matin aux loges
en josas près du siège de l'entreprise à
l'origine de ce projet le centre
permettra de ravitailler les
professionnels avec du carburant un
nouvelle génération il sera à 100%
écologique et ne produira aucun à gaz à
effet de serre les détails avec ce sujet
de michael et demi d'euros un nouveau
carburant arrive dans les yvelines
stations d'hydrogène a été inauguré ce
mercredi 28 mars aux loges en josas
cette énergie verte fabriqué à partir de
ressources renouvelables en normandie le
produira ni
gaz à effet de serre ni particules fines
recharge se fait en quelques minutes à
la pompe pour un prix équivalent à
l'essence c'est le même usage
un usage diesel ou essence à la
différence de la batterie ou vous devez
chargé des électrons là vous charger
directement du gaz dans un premier temps
la station sera utilisée principalement
par des bennes à ordures des taxis
présents sur le territoire et deux bus à
hydrogène sur la ligne 264 qui dessert
les villes de buc et de versailles
on commence par les premiers jeunes
parce que ça permet de développer des
logiques de flottes captives qui
reviennent sur les stations dont sa
famille de charger les stations n'py
vite et de les rendre rentable plus
facilement mais la vision à long terme
c'est que vous aurez aussi des voitures
particulières
j'ai quelques collaborateurs des états
unis qui tourne sur des voitures sur des
voitures hydrogène avec plaisir vous
avez plus de 7000 véhicules dans le
monde qui sont des véhicules
particuliers une vision à long terme qui
a séduit l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle comment
sauver la planète et toutes les
entreprises essayent maintenant de
s'inscrire dans cette nouvelle dynamique
coût total de ce projet 1,5 million
d'euros pour être rentable la station
doit accueillir entre 50 et 60 véhicules
par jour à terme la station prévoit
également de ravitailler en carburant
des vélos à hydrogène attrape les
rythmes scolaires continuent de faire
débat
hier soir plusieurs enseignants et
représentants syndicaux se sont
rassemblés devant la mairie
ces personnes s'opposent à la demande de
dérogation formulée au ministère de
l'éducation nationale par la ville
trappe souhaite le retour à la semaine
de quatre jours en maternelle mais veut
maintenir et quatre jours et demi en
élémentaire les opposants dénoncent un
passage en force de la mairie ils ont
pris la parole lors du conseil municipal
réactions recueillies par annie caullet
kirillovitch 33 conseil d'école sur 36
se sont prononcés pour un retour aux
quatre jours et cela monsieur le maire
veut nous mettre devant le fait accompli
sur une expérimentation avec la
suppression du sein du mercredi matin
pour les
pour les maternelles donc soit une perte
de 108 heures
de 108 heures à l'année les enseignants
se sont exprimés il y a eu des sondages
d'effectuer donc on peut pas dire que la
parole leur paille n'aura pas été donné
maintenant le résultat de ces sondages
montrent qu'une écrasante majorité et
pour le retour à quatre jours et guy
malandain le maire de trappes a répondu
à ses déclarations il a notamment
indiqué que le maintien des quatre jours
et demi en élémentaire serait bénéfique
pour les écoliers le retour à quatre
jours en maternelle répond lui en
revanche à une fatigue des plus petits
lu ministère le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
elle n'a toujours pas indiqué s'il
acceptait ou non à cette demande de
dérogation en ce début de journal nous
évoquions cet hommage national au
lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame notre
dossier de la rédaction est justement
ont consacré cette semaine aux métiers
de la gendarmerie des yvelines ce soir
plongez au coeur du centre d'appels
d'urgence à versailles sur place plus
d'une quinzaine de personnes se relaient
jour et nuit pour répondre aux appels
des habitants
l'objet de ces appels varie énormément
et demande une concentration maximale 10
agents reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
jean votre nom ne sait comment votre
prénom
vous touchez un gendre une patrouille
tout se joue en l'espace de quelques
instants pour réunir les informations
nécessaires et engagé si besoin une ou
plusieurs patrouilles ici au centre
d'opérations et de renseignement de la
gendarmerie 150 à 200 appels sont gérés
par jour
plusieurs personnes sont ainsi présentes
sur place pour répondre aux yvelinois
qui compose le 17
et gérer des cas qui peuvent varier du
simple accident domestique aux
agissements les plus graves
on peut aussi avoir des gens qui sont en
urgence parce que ils sont sur le point
de se faire assassiner ça a été on a eu
ce cas là une femme qui s'effectue en
direct par exemple eh bien on a eu la
chance de pouvoir lui demander où est ce
qu'elle était et qu'elle a donné à la
donner
sa position en fait on est arrivé
c'était trop tard mais mais l'auteur
était resté sur place et son mari en
l'occurrence on peut aussi avoir des
gens qui sont tout petits des enfants ou
des personnes plus âgées où il faut
parler plus fort ce qu'ils entendent par
la clau
au total dix huit gendarmes se relaient
jour et nuit pour assurer le
fonctionnement du centre d'appels parmi
eux le chef fabien p o
alors le civet qu'est ce que tu m'as dit
que tu avais comme une peugeot 309 c'est
ça pour être opérationnel il a dû suivre
une formation et développer de nouvelles
capacités faut avoir un sens de l'écouté
il faut avoir une certaine une certaine
rigueur dans la retranscription des
événements et il faut avoir un certain
sang-froid de telle sorte à ce qu'on
soit pas embarquer entre guillemets par
l'affect de la personne qui nous
appellent et qui peut-être en panique
tous les personnels ont déjà un vécu
déjà avant on a tous été en brigade
donc voilà on vous prend pas des jeunes
sortis d'école il ya déjà un passif
faire passer tous les personnels ici ont
un sang froid et surtout se mettre dans
leur bulle quand il on l'appelle l'appel
justement celui ci ne dépasse pas
généralement plusieurs minutes
une série de questions simples et
basiques permet de faire un état des
lieux et de mesurer la gravité de la
pelle ce premier contact permet aussi
d'assurer la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre engagé sur place et nous on a
une difficulté de perception des
événements
ça peut avoir d'assez lourd de
conséquences sur les victimes mais ça
peut être ça peut avoir aussi d'autres
conséquences plus lourdes sur les
personnels de secours qui vont
intervenir l'an passé le centre
d'opérations et de renseignement de la
gendarmerie de versailles a reçu près de
110 mille appels
ceux ci ont entraîné l'intervention
d'une patrouille dans un cas sur trois
saint quentin en yvelines a va
renouveler cette année son p lachy le
programme local de l'habitat
intercommunale il fixera les grandes
orientations du logement sur le
territoire jusqu'à l'année 2023 pour en
parler deux invités il
longs de chambon soir bonsoir vous êtes
le vice président du coc d'esquisser le
conseil de développement économique de
saint quentin en yvelines
alors vous avez contribué à la phase de
diagnostic de ce plh et on va en parler
dans un instant avec le également
richard tellier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur du claj le clash c'est
le comité local pour le logement
autonome des jeunes sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
vous allez nous livrer dans un instant
les le diagnostic sur ce plh i il
présente d'ailleurs un point de tension
au niveau de la population jeune on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
déjà quelques éléments de présentation
sur vos structures respectives qu'est ce
que le connais ce qui alors locaux des
skis donc c'est le conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines les conseils de développement
ont été créées par la loi en 99 et
pierre infléchi la loi nôtre ce sont
donc un conseil consultatif constitué de
membres bénévoles qui sont désignés par
les élus qui sont issus de milieux
économiques associatifs ou citoyens et
qui sont chargés soit sur saisine des
des élus soit sur auto saisine donc de
leur initiative de faire des
propositions aux élus de réfléchir aux
politiques publiques du territoire et de
faire des propositions
alertés les le clash qu'est ce que c'est
alors les clashs sont issus d'une
circulaire interministérielle qui date
de 1990 le clash de saint quentin lui
est né en 1994 avec deux missions
principales la première c'est une
mission d'accueil du public jeune en
recherche de logement sur le territoire
c'est de l'accompagnement aux démarches
de recherche de logement une mission va
dire d'animation du partenariat local
c'est réunir des acteurs concernés par
le logement et l'insertion des jeunes
afin de trouver des solutions en
fonction des besoins qui sont exprimées
par les jeunes donc c'est une réunion de
foyers de jeunes travailleurs de la
mission locale de structures d'insertion
par le logement alors le codis qui a
contribué à la phase de diagnostic de ce
plan local de l'habitat intercommunale
j'en ai dit deux mots tout à l'heure à
quoi sert un plh y alors le plh le
programme local de l'habitat donc y
comme intercommunale
c'est un document de programmation de la
politique du logement en grande partie
de la politique du logement et en
particulier de la construction de
logements neufs pour les années 2010 8
2023 pour cela qu'on ne lâche pas c'est
un document qui est assez détaillée et
donc c'est un document très important
pour le pour l'agglomération et pour
l'ensemble de de la politique de la
politique du logement alors le
diagnostic que vous avez produit fait
une trentaine de pages quelle grande
conclusion vous avez voulu mettre en
avant
alors d'abord nous nous obstinons est du
point de vue des habitants à se dire que
il y a de toute façon des services de
l'agglomération qui font des diagnostics
très très précis très fouillée très
intéressant d'ailleurs d'accord sur les
aspects purement logement nous nous
sommes partis des produits des habitants
et donc de la démographie et de
l'évolution de la population de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc d'abord on a constaté que depuis
2006 depuis huit ans saint quentin en
yvelines à une population qui est stable
alors que la région les différents
départements de la région
les intercommunalités similaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notamment les
anciennes mines nouvelle mais pas qu'eux
sont en croissance de 4 6 et 8% sur sur
cette période très bien donc
donc il ya un souci pas parce que il ya
quand même un dynamisme de la région et
la région attend que les
intercommunalités ne peut répondre aux
besoins et comment l'exposition très
justement alors comment l'expliquer
alors d'abord ça se décompose en d'une
part ya une croissance naturelle qui est
forte qui doit 1,1 pour cent par an à la
croix là la différence entre les
naissances et les décès et donc si on a
une population qui est stable ça veut
dire que il ya un solde migratoire
négatif qui est du même ordre de
grandeur
voilà donc ces c'est sur le solde
migratoire que se joue l'avenir de saint
quentin en yvelines 2 il est des
caractéristiques de la population
donc on a examiné ce solde migratoire
sous différents angles 1 par park
parages par géographie pour
avec différentes vous pas par nature
aussi de ménage ta taille des ménages ce
qui est le plus éclairant pour commencer
c'est la structure par âge on s'aperçoit
que tant du point de vue des volumes que
du solde c'est effectivement dans la
tranche 20 à 35 ans que l'essentiel se
passe d'accord voilà donc quand on fait
la combinaison entre ce solde migratoire
l'évolution naturelle de la population
et et d'autres facteurs
au bout du compte on a une population
qui dans les 20 34 ans décroît très
fortement à partir de 65 ans elle croît
très fortement
et puis la population des des familles
donc les 35-50 ans de 55 et leurs
enfants décroît très légèrement le ton
avance vite qu'ailleurs il va monter du
logement à saint quentin en yvelines
on a on travaille actuellement à faire
des propositions aux élus sur le nombre
de logements qu'il faudrait réaliser
dans ce programme et dans ce programme
local de l'habitat nous
ce que nous observons actuellement c'est
que
le solde migratoire est constitué à 50 5
% de ménages d'une personne de personnes
seules 25% de ménage de deux personnes
donc ça au total 80 % de ménages d'une
ou deux personnes
donc c'est vraiment du côté des petits
logements accessibles que va se jouer
certainement l'avenir de la révolte de
l' équilibre de la population de saint
quentin en yvelines alors le ton avant
ce but on va avoir le temps juste de
faire très rapidement un petit point sur
la demande des jeunes en termes de
logements sur le territoire riche à
réaliser c'est d'être très schématique
gérer un double objectif sur saint
quentin en yvelines satisfaire la
demande locale 90% des jeunes comme
celle site
il sut du territoire souhaite y rester
c'est bon signe il sera attaché à saint
quentin en yvelines mais 35% des jeunes
dont on a recueilli la demande à travers
un observateur partenariale qui
recensait en 2016 puis 2652 membres 35 %
des demandes sont liées à une mobilité
liée à l'emploi ou à la formation
premiers pôles d'activité des yvelines
donc des jeunes qui ont besoin de
solutions flexibles sur le territoire
pour venir travailler ou se former c'est
ça le double défi du territoire qui sont
les jeunes généralement yves l'adie des
petits ménages des ménages avec des
petites ressources 50% des jeunes ont
des ressources inférieures ou égales à
1000 euros en recherche d'un logement
autonome c'est à dire qu'il faille être
en capacité de mobiliser une offre de
petite taille à un prix accessible
le parc saint jean qui ont déjà conclure
des objets rapidement est un petit peu
inadapté de ce point de vue là puisqu'on
a une majorité de logements de quatre
pièces et plus non pas du tout en phase
avec les besoins exprimés par les jeunes
merci à vous d'avoir été avec ton
richard tellier directeur du claj comité
local pour le logement autonome des
jeunes à saint quentin en yvelines merci
également à lui longtemps d'avoir été
avec noah vice président du coc des skis
le conseil et de développement de saint
quentin en yvelines pour plus
d'informations sur le plh y le col skis
ou encore le claj vous invite à vous
rendre sur les deux sites internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran on reste à
saint quentin en yvelines avec ce procès
simulé c'est l'exercice auquel se sont
prêtés
hier mardi des étudiants en master 2 de
droit pénal de l'entreprise de l'ue vs
qu un entraînement pour ces jeunes qui
auront terminé dans quelques semaines à
leur cursus et seront confrontés au
monde du travail
ce faux procès permet aux étudiants de
s'exprimer dans un registre
professionnel et 2
ce sortir d'eux mêmes propos recueillis
par nicolas kirillovitch on les met en
situation de plaider ou de requérir
selon qu'ils sont avocats de la défense
parties civiles ou procureur de la
république devant une juridiction
simuler composé d'un avocat qui les a
préparés pendant de longues semaines
pour cet exercice et puis
d'universitaires culture pour refermer
ce journal nous vous en parlions la
semaine dernière ce week-end se tenait
les premières dates du festival le rire
soleil plusieurs représentations dont le
spectacle du directeur artistique de
l'événement éric bouvron ce spectacle
africa était présenté au public dimanche
dernier à jouy en josas
l occasion pour mélanie poké nicolas
landry de faire un point sur ce festival
regarder comment ça se fait eh bien je
suis plan parce que mon père est
français
ma mère y je suis né en egypte j'ai
grandi en afrique du sud
et c'est tout
une afrique du sud qu'il aime par dessus
tout et les bouvron en dresse un
portrait intime et drôle où est ce que
on trouve nos racines
c'est là où on a grandi j'y pense je
pense comment l'enfant en ressent les
choses tellement forte
ça nous marque et donc on a toujours
besoin de retourner à ce cocon avec
africa il bouvron accompagné de son
acolyte matos invite le public à
découvrir l'autre les autres une ode à
la générosité
[Musique]
cette maman ma mère qui m'a appris ça le
côté grec aussi d'accueillir et de dodi
de données j'aspire ouvert et généreux
on dit souvent comédiens soient généreux
la générosité cdh est vulnérable et être
près de rater aussi un spectacle qui
unit pour faire rire
eric bouvron est aussi le directeur
artistique du rire soleil un festival
fait de représentation et d'ateliers au
sein des écoles avec un mot clé le rire
l'humour et fédérateur déjà ça réunit
les gens se la met ensemble et s'auto je
suis pas fan des rares les temps sont
durs il faut il faut qu'on rit j'ai
envie que les gens partagent un moment
de bien quelque part un festival qui
prendra fin le 30 mars prochain cette
fois c'est arnaud cosson philibeaux et a
nié ce pacte qui auront la mission de
vous faire rire et encore plus d'art de
spectacles et d'expositions à suivre ce
soir dans le 7-8 culture de mélanie
poquet c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
merci de l'avoir suivi
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]